have you heard about this universal
basic income thing I have heard
something about have heard about this RS
well I guess then can you define
universal basic income for those who
have no idea I'm giving that me this is
a freaking softball man here you go
yes universal basic income is a policy
where every member of a society let's
say every US citizen gets a certain
amount of money to meet your basic needs
no questions asked so my proposal the
freedom dividend would put $1,000 a
month in the hands of every American
adult starting at age 18 to do whatever
you want and that's universal basic
income it sounds dramatic now in 2019
but Thomas Paine was forward at the
founding of the country Martin Luther
King champion in the 1960s Milton
Friedman and a thousand economist signed
the study saying this would be great for
America also in the 60s and 70s it
passed the US House of Representatives
twice in 1971 under Nixon and one state
has had a dividend for almost 40 years
where everyone in Alaska now gets
between one and two thousand dollars a
year so I know at first blush everyone
getting $1,000 a month sounds very
dramatic and almost too good to be true
but it actually is very very deeply
rooted in American thought and when you
say everyone you mean the person that's
from someone that's unemployed to
someone that is worth 20 million bucks
they're both getting that thousand
dollars yep that's right okay now how
are we gonna pay for this thing right
that has to be the next question yes so
so first it ends up costing a lot less
than most people think and there are a
few reasons for this number one is that
about half of Americans are already
getting direct support from the
government in some form so my dividend
would be universal but it's opt in and
if you opt in you forego benefits from
certain existing programs so the
headline cost goes down a lot very
quickly so okay so this is like someone
that's that's getting some other social
welfare or something and then if they
choose to take the ubi so like what type
of thing would they lose like food
stamps early yes well it's it's full
food stamps housing subsidies fuel
subsidies
cash and cash like programs that we have
about 120 welfare programs most of which
are cash or cash like so this excludes
Medicaid but it would include food
stamps and most other welfare programs
right and can you can you split the
difference on that so could you say I'm
gonna only take 500 a month ubi and I'm
gonna take you know 500 so you can so
you have to pick one basically yes yeah
and so I've talked to people who are on
various welfare programs and they love
the idea of getting $1,000 unconditional
because they dislike the case manager
the reporting requirements everything
else and so you can reduce the
enrollments in our existing program
significantly and so and it brings down
the headline cost very quickly because
if someone's already getting $700 and
benefits then that cost is $300 instead
of a thousand do we have good accounting
numbers on actually how much people are
getting like I'm gonna guess that a
certain amount of people it may be one
thing for food stamps but when you talk
about housing subsidies and things like
that that has to be way more I mean the
one that I always use is that my sister
and her husband live in New York City
struggling to get by they both have
full-time jobs two kids you can imagine
how expensive schools are and just
living in Manhattan and the right out of
it and half of their building is market
price and half is rent subsidized and
then what happens is and I know you know
this is that generation after generation
live in the same apartment then for like
you know 400 bucks and then my sister
your husband end up paying 4000 bucks
for a tiny two bedrooms so that people
people basically just get locked in
these programs where if you were to say
to the guy that's living in an apartment
for six hundred bucks here's the
thousand bucks you got to get going
nobody's gonna do it you'd have to be an
idiot to do it basically well I I think
knowing when I know about New York and
the subsidized rents it's not a federal
program I don't believe and so that
their situation might be that they
actually get the thousand bucks and then
they that it's helpful to them but in
terms of the math it ends up reducing
the headline cost of this by hundreds of
billions of dollars very very quickly
because people will either not opt in or
if they do opt in it costs a lot less
than a thousand dollars ahead so that's
reason number one where that reduces the
cost from like a top-line let's call
three trillion a year it goes down
pretty quickly
the second big
thing is that the money doesn't
disappear in our hands it ends up
getting circulated through the economy
over and over again what I call the
trickle op economy and so if you see
that it would end up increasing consumer
buying power and besides the economy by
about 10 to 12 percent we would generate
hundreds of billions a new tax revenue
just on the basis of more economic
activity in our society
we'd also save hundreds of billions on
things like incarceration homelessness
services emergency room health care and
things that were already spending about
a trillion on meaning because people are
gonna use that money for those things
either that or we have to we get to
spend less on it so one of the examples
that and is gonna sound very politician
II so apologize but I was in New
Hampshire and corrections officer in New
Hampshire said we should pay people to
stay out of jail because I gotta give me
their name and tell me but you're there
arm around them in the hole you know I
didn't have it up for a pie was there
and and and so we we think we're saving
money but we end up spending the money
on the back end anyway if someone ends
up falling through the cracks and they
land in our institutions our
institutions are incredibly expensive
and at least one estimate was that if
you reduce poverty in this country you
would increase our GDP by seven hundred
billion dollars just on the basis of
higher graduation rates better physical
health and better mental health so we're
gonna get back a lot of the money but
the big change we need to make too bit
to pay for this dividend is that right
now Amazon trillion-dollar tech company
paid zero in federal taxes last year net
flix zero in federal taxes less than you
did on this awesome operation and you
know Amazon's investing billions in AI
it's going to be one of the mega winners
from the fourth Industrial Revolution so
we need to have a mechanism where the
American people actually get some of
that and so my big proposal is that we
have to join every other advanced
economy in the world and have a
value-added tax that then gets the
American public a tiny slice of every
Amazon sale every Google search every
Facebook ad every robot truck mile and
because our economy is now so vast at 20
trillion dollars even a mild value-added
tax generates over 800 billion in new
revenue
so that plus the savings from existing
programs plus the economic growth plus
the value gains enough to pay for a
dividend of $1,000 a month so I know
that a certain percentage of my audience
they know that generally I'm a small
government guy I want it to be I wanted
to be as small as it can be to function
as a general rule so it could be it
could be streamlined enough I want it to
exist well enough so that things are
working without all of the fat and all
of the pork and all the rest of it but
so some of my alarms go off here when
because of the idea that this would be
federal in nature so that a thousand
bucks if you live in say Los Angeles you
get you get next to nothing thousand
bucks if you live maybe and you know
somewhere in the middle of country
you're gonna get a lot more is there any
way you can compensate for any of that
or you or is that not even we're
thinking about in your estimation or
well there are a few reasons why it's
good it's a good idea to keep a uniform
number one is that there are other
reasons why people live in LA often not
just the weather but but access to 398
yeah but access to certain economic
opportunities so you're making it
trade-off already and it's also very
hard to administer because the fact is
if you're getting paid more to live in
an expensive place a lot of people would
live expensive places that like sneak
off and right you know spend the money
someplace cheaper so it's much cleaner
for everyone to make it uniform it also
ends up fueling mobility in both
directions because at least some people
might feel like hey if I leave LA and go
you know go to Arizona like I can
actually live much better that you know
it's like it will help balance things
out what do you say just to the general
idea sort of I guess the the
philosophical idea that if you just keep
giving people things not eventually they
just start doing less for themselves
that a thousand bucks like yeah maybe
there's some place in the country that
you could live then you can play video
games all day and smoke pot all day and
and not really do much and that we're
gonna sort of we're gonna cushion
people's ability to to not just get up
and get going well that's what people
want that but that just human nature is
oh I start getting something and I can
just kind of ease up a little bit so
there are there are three things I would
say first I agree with your vision of
government and the great thing about
this is that this actually does not grow
federal bureaucracy what we all hate is
when you have money just flow up to the
pipes and then disappear and then you
know never see it again and you don't
know what the hell happened this
actually puts the economic resources
back in our hands it's one of the
reasons why the only state that's done
this is Alaska which is a deep red
conservative state passed by a
Republican governor and it's wildly
popular there like the dividends
everyone's favorite thing about what the
government does because it's not a giant
government program it's actually almost
cost for you to administer and just puts
money right into our hands so I agree
with your vision of government is that
the last thing I want is like in our new
army of bureaucrats running around so
what do you fear that even even if
everything you've said is completely on
point that any time you just the way
that the system works at least now that
any time you try to put in a giant
federal program that the bureaucrats and
just that middle management part of the
government will figure out ways like you
could be like it's real easy guys we got
320 million people in the country
everyone's getting a thousand bucks the
math works out it's like it's all good
but that then just the process of how
government works will create all sorts
of other problems well if you look at
the way they do it in Alaska it's
actually very lightweight like as long
as they can prove your last president
you're there it's like this how many
people you are like they have a very
very low level administrative burden
let's say so as long as you can pull
that off
which in my opinion like this is where
we have to go because because as the
economy is transforming and so so number
one I agree with your vision of small
government if we can achieve it and so
I'm going to come back to it but number
three yeah and that number two is number
two is the biggest misconception about
this that it's somehow are going to
reduce work and what I mean by this is
you put this money into our hands it has
a first it creates two million new jobs
immediately in the economy because just
more economic activity the smoothie shop
hires someone the mechanic needs a you
know an assistant like on and on through
the economy so more expendable income
more shopping occurs yeah pretty much
the easiest way to say that yes the
other thing though that it does it ends
up fueling a lot of the work that right
now our market does not recognize
so that's some of the stuff that you've
done throughout your career like arts
creativity entrepreneurship like a lot
of that stuff doesn't get recognized by
the market till you become if you know
frankly like successful but also work
like my wife does my wife's at home with
our two boys one of whom is autistic and
the market values her work at zero even
though it's incredibly hard and
incredibly important so it's not that
putting this money into our hands
somehow makes us work less
it creates conventional work it ends up
also fueling the sort of work that we
want to do so that that's number two and
then number three is this notion of
what's happening in our economy if you
look around at the fact that suicides
and drug overdoses have overtaken
vehicle deaths for the first time in
American history our life expectancy has
declined for the last three years almost
unheard of in a developed country you
know the last time our life expectancy
decline three years in a row I guess it
was probably like the late 1920s
something like that yeah it was the
Spanish flu of 1918 it's like where I
killed millions of people and so and
this buzz saw is just going to
accelerate when a eye comes in starts
getting rid of call center workers and
bookkeepers and accounts and the rest of
it and so when you're facing a set of
changes that that's this mammoth putting
cash into people's hands actually the
most lightweight thing you can do some
of the other proposals that are out
there are the ones that we must avoid
which are things like like a jobs
guarantee or like creating like a whole
new array of of subsistence jobs for
massive difference you have than some of
the other Democratic candidates right
because Bernie and I think Elizabeth
Warren and a couple of others are
talking about a federal got jobs
guarantee without which to me again as a
basically a small government guy that
sounds horrible to me like that that
sounds like indentured servitude to me
yes one of the things it's like why not
just get everyone gray overalls while
you're at give us the uniform it will
flip wage it's all day and that's it
yeah so I try and point out obvious
things it's like hey what if someone
doesn't like the job they have what if
they're bad at it what if they don't
like their boss what if their boss
doesn't like them what if the job
actually like you know turns out
don't need it after a while like if
you're literally dependent upon a
government job to survive and like
actually have food on the table then all
of those things become existential and
you end up creating a whole new army of
bureaucrats to administer this like
massive jobs program so I'm for
infrastructure creating jobs like
because those are jobs you know you need
we need to rebuild the infrastructure
but starting out saying we're in a
guarantee having a job is exactly what
we have to avoid so so when they say
that when you hear them say that do you
honestly think that they believe that is
the right thing to do or even a feasible
thing to do or that they're just saying
because it sounds if you're not really
thinking about these issues that hard to
me saying free everything sounds good it
all sounds good free college free this
free job you know all these things just
if you're not thinking it's just like oh
great free why not let's do it if you're
young and you haven't really put the the
acumen in to figure out what these
things one of the dangers is that a lot
of these politicians have never actually
run a business worked in a business
understand what the mechanics of these
organizations look like on the ground
they're just lurching from press release
to fundraiser to cable news hit and they
don't understand what a Lib reality
would be for a person who has to show up
and like check in for their their McJob
and the institutionalization of this
thinking it is sincere like it's not
like if you poke the person who's for
Federal jobs guarantee they're like yeah
I was just kidding no no I mean but I'd
like to actually feel that what they
feel it right but I guess feeling it and
knowing are two different things
well I mean they they believe it let's
put it that way they're sincere in their
belief and and so if you buy that we're
in the midst of the greatest economic
transformation in the history of the
world which we are and then in my mind
you wind up with like a couple of major
models to try and respond to it and my
model is put economic buying power in
the hands of every adult as fast as
possible and help us rebuild our own
communities our own lives our own
families and like find new forms of work
that we find fulfilling and purposeful
the other model in my opinion is a
government trying to figure out what
sort of work we find people and
purposeful yeah and
this to me is what we must avoid at all
costs right well it's also a
self-perpetuating thing right because
then the government always has to grow
we always have more people we will
always need more jobs so they will
always keep bringing more and more
people into the system yeah and to give
you a sense of the immediacy of this as
we're sitting here together in your 10
minute end of an expansion the US labor
force participation rate is close to a
multi-decade low of 63 percent the same
levels as Ecuador and Costa Rica wait
say that in 63 percent of working-age
Americans are presently in the workforce
hmm so when we hear this thing about job
yeah that unemployment is at an all-time
lower this type of thing that doesn't
factor in that people just have checked
out right that's basically what you're
getting yeah and if you remember Kennedy
Trump in 2015 he was like oh this
headline unemployment number is fake
news it's bunk 95 million Americans out
of the workforce and now he's in office
and he's like oh like that it's great he
was right the first time because if you
leave the workforce
you're not calculated into the headline
unemployment number it also doesn't
include the fact that 94 percent of the
new jobs created since 2005 are
temporary gig or contract jobs it
doesn't include the fact that 44 percent
of recent college graduates are
underemployed in a job that doesn't
require a degree so the headline
unemployment number is at best
misleading and incomplete at worst
[ __ ] like it's it's somewhere in
that range right so what what about I
think a start song a certain set of
people would basically say well alright
some of some of this is making sense and
I can see why I would get rid of some of
bureaucracy and you're not you're doing
a governmental program but not totally
expanding the government but why not
just do it for people under say $50,000
so that you don't need to give it to the
guy that's making 75,000 that lives in
Kansas City who's got a decent life
but why not just give it to the people
50 men you know whatever that whatever
the number I'm gonna come up with sure
there there are a few reasons so one of
the reasons why it's a wildly popular in
Alaska is that it's universal so it's
not like go rich Alaskans don't get it
prostitutes is like no you live here
it's a right of citizenship you get your
dividend and so by making it so it's not
a rich to poor transfer you D stigmatize
it you universalize it and then you make
it more politically popular because it's
just something that we all
as citizens and owners and shareholders
of the richest most advanced country in
the history of the world
number two you get rid of any incentive
to underreport your income or to have
monitoring requirements let's say I'm
married to someone who's not working and
then maybe we could be like hey how
about we file separately and then you'd
make nothing and then you can get the
dividend and removes the cliff situation
where you'd actually want to earn less
right this is one of the ones that I've
struggled with the most about this about
the general idea not the way you were
laying it out but that I I don't like
things that D incentivize people to make
more and I could you know you mentioned
this thing before about it you could
struggle for a long time and then
suddenly you're making more and it's
like last year I paid more in taxes than
I had ever made in my entire life before
that and like that so I don't like the
idea that the more work you do the more
value you bring the more you sort of get
punished yeah and that's one of the
problems with our current welfare
programs like and the extreme examples a
friend of mine his sister's on
disability she was afraid to volunteer
at a non-profit because she was afraid
someone would say you're healthy and
then take away her her benefits I mean
what a terrible incentive that is but
most welfare programs are constructed
such that if you flourish then you get
less whereas if you have a dividend
that's universal you know you do nothing
you get the dividend you do something
you get the dividend then like your
incentives actually to do something so
why not just blow apart so that I think
the best libertarian argument that I've
heard for you be is that basically if
you want to do UVI it's got the right
idea why not just blow apart the social
safety net as is take because we know
it's just a boondoggle of
middle-management nonsense
with all the whacked-out incentives that
you're talking about why not just take
all of that money which I do we even
know how much money is actually put into
these things of course so how much right
now
um six hundred billion give or take give
or take all right so why not take the
six hundred billion that are on programs
that we know are creating as many
problems probably as they're fixing if
not more and then do it that way like do
you think cuz it almost feels like it's
like a little bit of a stopgap that
you'd still have to get to that problem
eventually oh well that's the beauty of
this the freedom dividend proposal is
that you have the six hundred billion or
so and then you're saying hey guess what
like
it's now a new rate of citizenship
everyone gets it and then what's going
to happen is you're going to
dramatically reduce the enrollment in
these programs very very quickly because
a lot of people would be like I prefer
the cash and then then this new incoming
population would just opt for the
dividend and then never end up on these
welfare programs so you would end up
shrinking the enrollments over time and
the way you describe you just wouldn't
do it all at once
because you know there are a lot of
people in very distinct situations and
this is actually much more politically
feasible and popular than going and
trying to tear these programs up and you
know from from the roots up yeah are you
worried though that the that because
states have different things related to
social programs that I mean we sort of
addressed this already but just that
different states will deal with it so
differently in terms of how they're
giving benefits off UVI that it just is
gonna create this we may have a
gajillion people moving to one state
leaving another state or the rest of it
or you just think that that's well
that's one reason why having uniform
benefits because right now there are
block grants that go to various days in
the states do different things with it
as you're suggesting and those are the
programs that would be swapped out for
ubi so the more people that opt into ubi
then the like smaller those grants would
be
[Music]